STEVEN HALL: So one of the
nice things about this approach
is that, first of all, the
students are always engaged.
They're actively engaged
in their learning.
They're not passively
listening to me
try to explain the important
features of a problem.
By standing up and
working at the board,
I can see what all
the students are doing
in the room at the same time.
So I can tell from
across the room
if a group is having trouble.
I can tell from the
middle of the room
if the entire class
is maybe lost.
So it gives me a lot of options.
I can go help students
who are having trouble.
I can stop the class.
I can lecture a little bit to
help with a broad misconception
that they may have.
But more importantly, when
the students are standing,
they're much more likely
to share the responsibility
for doing the problem.
What I've found is that when
they're working at tables, even
if we ask them to work
together, the tendency
is to turn to the piece
of paper in front of them
and work alone.
But by standing up,
sharing a blackboard,
no one can monopolize.
Anyone can step in
and do a problem.
So in a conventional class,
the opportunities for feedback
are essentially, when you
grade the problem sets,
you have some inkling
of whether students
understand the material.
But really, you learn
whether students
know the material at the quiz
at which point it's too late.
The students have already scored
perhaps poorly on the quiz.
But by then, you've moved
on to other material.
So one of the nice things
about active learning
is that it provides feedback
at multiple times scales.
So in a lecture, if you have
a concept quiz on material
that you've just
lectured, you might
discover that the lecture
was completely ineffective.
Or you might discover that
it was very effective,
and you can move
on to new material.
The same is true in recitation.
Especially in the
recitations that I've
been doing in 16.06 where
we emphasize skills,
you can see over the weeks
the progression of skills.
Students get better and
better at a core skill
that they need later on.
And in our case, it's things
like root locus and Bode plots.
You can really see week to
week that they get much better
at what they're doing.